si vous êtes intéressé par des histoires avec des
fins heureuses cette histoire est diffusée
ailleurs, je conseillerais à tous nos téléspectateurs
de regarder quelque chose de plus agréable à l'
étude Je suis le comte Olaf votre nouveau gardien
où sont vos mains maintenant nous sommes orphelins
mettez-les au travail dans le  moulin cette
économie les enfants ont de la chance d'avoir un
travail votre première impression de moi peut
être que je suis une personne terrible quand
allons-nous manger
mais vous n'avez pas la moindre idée vous
devez comprendre qu'il a eu une
enfance très terrible don  je n'ai pas l'air si déprimé de
rire une enfance très terrible en ce
moment d'accord nos parents ne
reviendront jamais nous sommes tous effrayés Klaus mère
et père ils m'ont fait promettre de
toujours veiller sur toi laisse moi tenir ma
promesse
tu es enfin en sécurité maintenant les enfants juste  comme
vos parents voulaient trouver votre tante
Josefina
elle peut vous dire tout ce que vous devez
savoir vivez-vous avec sa tante Joséphine
je suis ta tante Joséphine bonjour
je suis stefano il est l'après-midi et votre
comte Olaf
le sur  La raison pour laquelle ma voiture Olaf ne t'a pas dit
membre à membre est parce qu'il n'a pas mis la
main sur ta fortune
tu ne t'en sortiras jamais avec ça leur
fortune sera la mienne
carpe diem saisir les enfants taquiner le
jour où j'ai dit jour
[Musique  ]
dont le ciel ne me souriait que bleu
ciel
violet Klaus et ensoleillé étaient des enfants intelligents la
plupart de tout ce qui leur
arrivait n'était que malheur et désespoir
vos parents ont péri dans un terrible
incendie péri signifie tué nous savons ce que
péri signifie bonjour bonjour bonjour les
enfants
je suis  Comte Olaf votre nouveau gardien savez-
vous ce que c'est ça ressemble à une liste
fausse c'est une liste une liste de tâches nous
savons que vous essayez juste de voler
la fortune d'un parent nous devons sortir de
cet endroit misérable retourner à la maison
où c'est sûr et où les étrangers ne peuvent pas vous trouver des
étrangers où les
enfants Baudelaire seront détruits hmm
quand le sable s'épuisera cette fortune est à
moi je n'avais pas réalisé que le soleil est allé si
vite je l'ai acheté en ligne
d pour le retourner plusieurs fois tes
parents et moi t'avons élevé développer nos propres
codes secrets
nos parents développent des codes secrets dans ma
bibliothèque tu trouveras toutes les réponses
dont tu as besoin mettons-nous au travail
quelque chose d'étrange se passe qu'est-ce qu'il
y a quelque chose mes parents  on dirait
que le tatouage que le comte Olaf a sur sa
cheville
mon nom est le capitaine des chefs l'homme est vraiment le
comte Olaf déguisé n'êtes-vous pas intelligent
où que vous alliez je vais vous traquer pourquoi
nous détestez-vous tellement parce que c'est amusant que
nous installons  dans une expédition très top secrète
qu'est-ce que tu dis Baudelaires
es-tu dans
Je t'emmène en prison bien bonne chance
avec ça je suis armé
donc mon jeu d'enfant hmm adorable hmm c'est
un fusil harpon
toi